the grill at this saskatoon restaurant
might be hot but thanks to kovid
business has cooled people they don't
feel very safe to go out
and that's why the business is slow two
years of staying home masking social
distancing and then vaccinating to tamp
coveted spread has left many canadians
desperate for anything normal
and the idea of living with this
coronavirus is no longer novel moving
forward we'll be treating covert the way
we treat
say the seasonal flu or other
respiratory viruses that
that are circulating within the
community annual vaccines and common
sense hand washing and staying home when
sick will be our safety nets as experts
move away from recommending stringent
restrictions a new study out of johns
hopkins university suggests pandemic
lockdowns were not effective at reducing
mortality rates globally and a growing
list of countries are already opening up
most recently denmark and sweden they're
in a completely different situation than
we are regarding icus their icu numbers
are actually going down
a key indicator in making the move to
return to normal although
hospitalization numbers in ontario and
quebec appear to have plateaued across
western canada they are still rising
manitoba bc and saskatchewan with record
numbers this week the burden is largely
saddled from those reopening plans when
they don't go so well on the frontline
healthcare system making timing critical
and specific to each province if we see
another surge then we've taken the wrong
decision or somebody wasn't listening to
the to the evidence as it was going in
let's treat it carefully and cautiously
with the goal of a springer summer with
fewer masks and mandates but new
variants remain a variable too jamie
morocco global news toronto